bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce mercredi 14 juillet dernier défilé
sur les champs-elysées du siècle avec
ligne ou de lann-bihoué garde royale
marocaine en présence du roi du maroc
hassan ii hommage aux militaires
français engagés au kosovo lors de ce
défilé
jacques chirac serein au cours de
l'entretien télévisé à 13 heures il dit
non à ce qui n'incite au quinquennat
trou la cohabitation actuelle moins
difficiles que d'autres mais marc ses
différences avec le gouvernement jospin
sur la gestion des fruits de la
croissance
en iran les ayatollah conservateur
reprenne en main la situation l'ordre
règne des errants et la révolte des
étudiants est réprimée 10e étape du tour
de france cycliste avec une arrivée à
l'alpe d'huez l'italien guérini
l'emportent et les supporteurs de
richard virenque donne de plus en plus
de la voix
le traditionnel défilé du 14 juillet
s'est déroulée sous un ciel à peine
nuageux tout le programme a été rempli
en présence du président de la
république et du gouvernement et du roi
du maroc
on aura noté la forte présence du bagad
de lann-bihoué des 500 hommes de la
garde royale marocaine ont ni chambre
rouge et des nombreux éléments
militaires d'unités engagées au kosovo
commentaires avec les images du défilé
françois korber 10h20 ce matin devant la
tribune présidentielle place de la
concorde
l'aubade du bagad de lann-bihoué et de
la musique des équipages de la flotte de
brest
fumigènes bleu blanc rouge des alphajet
de la patrouille de france sur les
champs elysées pour l'ouverture de ce
défilé aérien
vedette de cette parade les avions de
l'armée de l'air et de l'aéronavale
engagés dans l'intervention de l'otan
contre la yougoslavie
au total 90 appareils qui ont effectué
20 % des missions de l'alliance menée
pendant 78 jours de raids sur la serbie
et le kosovo
en tête du défilé des troupes à pied la
musique et trois compagnies de la garde
royale marocaine au total 500 hommes
cette garde royale placée sous
l'autorité directe du roi est
l'héritière de la gare de noir défilé
des écoles polytechniques
saint cyr ou l'école des officiers de
saint maixent en cours on ne reçoit pas
du kosovo en ce 14 juillet 99 axé sur la
sécurité en europe avec ses
parachutistes du 8e régiment
d'infanterie de marine et la
participation ce matin rares dans un
défilé de cette compagnie de dragons
parachutistes formation de recherche de
pilotes abattus en territoire ennemi ou
de quête du renseignement derrière les
lignes un peloton du porte avions foch
qui a participé récemment avec son
aviation embarqué aux opérations en
adriatique
enfin la célèbre légion étrangère
marchand a sont pas accompagnés de sa
non moins célèbre musique venait
également de se défiler l'espion du ciel
le drone systèmes aériens d'observation
sans pilote qui ont connu leur baptême
du feu récemment procos au goût le must
de l'artillerie des lance-roquettes
multiples armes modernes dotés d'une
puissance de feu considérable
les pompiers de paris bien sûr présent
chaque année sur les champs elysées
suivi dans le ciel de la capitale des
transall ou des hercules de l'armée de
l'air qui ont fourni un effort important
et capital dans l'acheminement de l'aide
française aux réfugiés du kosovo dans
les camps de macédoine et d'albanie
modernité mais aussi tradition incarnée
par la garde républicaine à cheval qui a
clôturé ce défilé du 14 juillet le
dernier du siècle
alors c'était donc l'innovation la plus
spectaculaire de ce défilé les troupes
marocaines de la garde royale l'ex garde
noire du roi du maroc invité à descendre
les champs-elysées devant hassan ii dont
ils sont au service exclusif alors nous
avons suivi leurs préparations tôt ce
matin reportage maryse burgot et olivier
journiac le pantalon et bouffant les 150
pays ont été faits à la main ce matin
sur les champs elysées on n'avait d'yeux
que pour la traditionnelle tenue
d'apparat de la garde royale marocaine
pour la première fois depuis la
libération
un détachement d'une unité étrangère
autonome défile sur les champs elysées
pas un chien ne doit dépasser ces hommes
appartiennent à l'unité la plus
prestigieuse du maroc
celle qui est chargée de la protection
de la famille royale et donc du roi
assad
leur présence sur les champs en ce 14
juillet rappelle la participation
d'unités marocaine à la victoire de 45
contre les nazis dans la foule
d'ailleurs beaucoup de franco marocain
rendent hommage à ces combattants de
l'ex armée d'afrique
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour mombasa qui
est mort pour la france
et ça marche bien combattants de la
deuxième guerre mondiale mandron père
maison à tous les laits peuple marocain
qui a combattu auprès des français
au temps du protectorat français la
garde royale étaient surmenés la gare de
noir les troupes étaient recrutés au
couffin sud des territoires du sultan
les hommes y étaient jugés plus braves
et plus fort lorsque le maroc devint
indépendant la garde noire fut intégrée
aux nouvelles forces armées du pays
depuis le maroc a évolué et ses liens
avec la france aussi le roi hassan ii
était aujourd'hui l'invité d'honneur du
président un symbole fort
illustrant le renforcement des relations
entre les deux pays hassan ii qui pour
garantir la pérennité de sa dynastie a
accepté une démocratisation de son
régime
en nommant par exemple un premier
ministre issu de l'opposition sociale
sur le plan des droits de l'homme en
revanche quelques dossiers restent
délicats mais de cela on n'a pas parlé
aujourd'hui
bien sûr il y avait beaucoup de monde
pour voir applaudir et complimenter
l'armée française qui suppose quelques
anecdotes quelques commentaires
pittoresque et des omis des images
originales alors voici le reportage à
côté du défilé et en l'air avec une
équipe de 4 agnès guerbet florence
griffon alexis delcourt et malbec
c'est jour de fête alors il faut que ça
brille
il ya un mois à peine cet appareil était
encore au kosovo avec à son bord le
lieutenant ibères janot ce matin c'est
une autre histoire
c'est au dessus de paris qui va voler un
privilège qui ne lui donne pas le
vertige
c'est beau mais en attendant vous verrez
qu'on a très peu le temps d'en profiter
puisqu'on on est soucieux de garder sa
position par rapport aux autres
hélicoptères qui sont dans la formation
la formation est prête au départ pendant
ce temps la mise en scène commence sur
les champs elysées aurélie pour la pause
c'est pour sa maman venue de metz des
mois qu'elle attendait ça je stresse
parce que j'avais peur pas la voir
j'avais pas la première à épiler en
l'air le but approche les hélicoptères
resserrent les rangs au milieu de la
foule sur terre l'essentiel est de
trouver sa place et d'élever le regard
joseph triplant sa faillite
les chevaux sont lancés les hélicos si
la traversée deschamps n'aura duré que
vingt secondes
content de t'avoir professionnels
bobigny
certains 190 km heure le plaisir est
fugace mais là au moins il est partagé
partout dans le monde des cérémonies ont
eu lieu là où se trouvent des
communautés françaises et donc
naturellement au kosovo parmi les
troupes engagées au sein de forces
internationales de paix le général bruno
cuche président ait une prise d'armes à
mitrovica ce matin il a appelé au retour
à la paix et à l'harmonie dans une
province at-il dit meurtri et martyrisé
alors à l'issue du défilé la tradition
politico médiatique fait que le chef de
l'état accorde un entretien en direct
des jardins des lycées en compagnie
d'élise lucet de france 3 de patrick
poivre d'arvor de tf1 nous l'avons
interrogé sur les principaux thèmes
d'actualité pendant plus de 50 minutes
et pour commencer nous avons sollicité
de monsieur chirac un bilan de
l'engagement de la france au kosovo
cette action valait le coup d'autant que
slobodan milosevic est toujours au
pouvoir
milosevic aujourd'hui est à la fois
contesté dans son pays de façon me
semble-t-il croissante et deuxièmement
il est inculpé par le tribunal pénal
international
c'est à dire que il y a tout lieu de
penser comme le disait le président du
tribunal international didier ou
avant-hier qu'il paiera il paiera pour
les atrocités à l'origine desquelles ils
se trouvaient je crois qui sera
sanctionnée comme il le faut comme on
doit alors avant même cet entretien dans
son message aux armées de président de
la république demande est au
gouvernement de consacrer les moyens
indispensables à la politique de défense
en soulignant des lacunes dans le
dispositif militaire français
puis nous avons ce site et ses réponses
concernant la situation politique en
france après l'échec de la droite aux
élections européennes sur le quinquennat
souhaitait par valéry giscard d'estaing
sur la cohabitation mais également sur
ses différences en matière économique et
social avec le gouvernement de monsieur
jospin voici les principaux extraits des
réponses du président chirac
ce quinquennat
soula sous une forme ou sous une autre
ce serait une erreur et donc je ne la
prouverai pas et j'assumerai par
conséquent pour pour répondre ma mission
jusqu'à son terme et alors les français
jugeront elle en tirerons toutes les
conséquences
cette cohabitation je la qualifie gelé
qualifié l'année dernière de constructif
et je garde exactement un même terme
tous les régimes ont été les régimes de
cohabitation j'avoue cohabiter avec
monsieur giscard d'estaing mais d'autres
ont cohabité avec le giro car ça a
toujours été
j'aime l'école il ne faut pas croire que
la cohabitation était forcément plus
facile lorsqu'elle était plus voilé
et si je devais donc lui donner conseils
parce que dans une démocratie il faut
une opposition aux fortes qui aient pour
vocation pour ambition de reprendre le
pouvoir c'est ça le jeu de la démocratie
je ne dirai de faire un vrai effort de
réconciliation de dialogue d'élaboration
d'un projet commun fondé sur une vision
commune de l'avenir et qui n'est pas
celle de la gauche elle peut le faire si
elles règlent ce problème je dirais un
peu de de querelles personnelles et
coeur et les tripes
si vous voulez fond de ma pensée sont
vraiment aujourd'hui insupportable
nous avons depuis deux ans
delacroix tendu
une conscience je dirais pratiquement
inespéré et qui fait que nous avons
aujourd'hui l'expression est un peu
triviale énormément d'argent qui rentre
dans les caisses comme toujours en
période quand on est dans cette
situation et je dirais qu'il faut''
avoir trois objectifs prioritaires
il faut d'abord réduire les réduire les
dettes qui pèseront sur ceux qui nous
suivent
deuxièmement il faut rendre au pouce et
une part de ce qu'on l'a appris au bt
les apporte les impôts et les chats la
fiscalité la fiscalité et les chats les
commandes diminuer les impôts et
troisièmement il faut en profiter pour
nous allons nous adapter faire les
adaptations nécessaires puissent quand
on a beaucoup d'argent
on peut s'adapter sans trop de douleur
je crois qu'il est urgent d'engager
cette réforme et je ferai ça prend deux
observations la première c'est que
notamment à ce titre il est essentiel de
créer une épargne retraite qui s'ajoute
à la retraite normale pour ceux qui le
désirent et surtout qui permettrait à la
france de reprendre le contrôle de ces
grandes entreprises
il n'y a aucune
il ya simplement le fait que la
séparation conduite à ce que la
responsabilité pénale du président de la
république ne peut être évoqué que
devant la haute cour de justice c'est
tout il sut quasi fonctions de président
naturellement et pour la durée de son
mandat
cela va de soi le conseil
constitutionnel n'a rien dit d'autre et
c'est tout à fait normal alors toujours
plutôt détendu le président s'est
ensuite fait un plaisir de se mêler dans
la foule des invités de l'elysée certes
ce n'était pas l'ambiance de l'année
dernière avec l'équipe de france de
football
mais la guerre d'une partir sans
rassembler quand même plusieurs milliers
de personnes célèbres ou non
reportage ironique intelligent paul
chaussée avec déjà quelques premières
réactions politiques aux propos de
monsieur chirac des poignées de mains
des embrassades
c'est en maîtresse de maison que
bernadette chirac accueil sur le perron
sur la pelouse
ia les jeunes ce sont eux que l'elysée a
voulu mettre en valeur deux mille
lycéens des branchés qui ont créé des
sites internet les élégances sont
contrastées
même si quelques anciens font de la
résistance devant moi
ouais le service d'ordre est débordé le
président de la république est immergé
jacques chirac superstar ne refuse aucun
autographe
le président de la république vient
d'indiquer qu'il ira au terme de son
mandat quelques mètres plus loin on
commente la dernière fois que le public
a pris l'initiative d'en haut c'était la
dissolution
vraiment je comprends qu'ils veuillent
plus grande initiative d'en haut moi je
suis contre la cohabitation mais les
français ont l'air de saverne leur
plaire je le regrette parce que je pense
que mon pays ne va pas assez vite sous
ne change pas assez vite fait que en
trop des systèmes qui ne sont pas
adaptables
le premier ministre lui prend la pose
il ne commentera pas les propos
présidentiels au plus près de la base
c'est donc la stratégie de jacques
chirac décidés plus que jamais à se
dégager des parties le président de la
république il est là pour maintenir une
certaine stabilité une autorité de la
france à l'étranger et vino a nié aussi
que notre salut ne pourra venir que de
nous et qu' il n'était pas le chef de
l'opposition il est le président de la
république gardien des institutions
rouille de nos positions rôle de la
majorité et jean pierre chevènement qui
fait la morale
une fois encore la garden party aura
donc permis au président de la
république et à ses hôtes de prendre
date
rendez vous après les vacances si pour
le président délégué de l'udf
hervé de charette monsieur chirac a
tracé les pistes et montrer qu'il était
le meilleur atout de l'opposition pour
le mouvement démocratie libérale et
monsieur goasguen qui souhaitaient le
passage au quinquennat pour le mandat
présidentiel la déconvenue est clair
réactions recueillies par ilana
moryoussef il ya eu un choix du
président de la république ce choix
repousse le quinquennat nous respectons
ce choix
il n'y avait pas d'ailleurs de bonnes
solutions à vrai dire il était
souhaitable que le président la
république réponde clairement oui ou non
il a répondu non
la cohabitation durable n'est pas non
plus une solution parfaite dans la
mesure elle présente des risques
politiques incontestable mais nous
respectons le choix du président
alors quant au porte-parole du parti
socialiste alain claeys s'il a trouvé le
président affaibli j'ajoute que philippe
douste-blazy le président du groupe udf
à l'assemblée nationale qualifie le
président de pragmatique après son
intervention en pragmatique est plutôt
serein face aux demandes de ses amis
gérard coûté à l'affrontement jacques
chirac préfère clairement l'usure
beaucoup à droite attendaient que le
président durcissent la cohabitation
voire qu'il la casse jacques chirac que
s'ils refusent ils rejettent sans
ménagement l'idée de valéry giscard
d'estaing de démissionner pour instituer
un quinquennat qui dit-il n'éviterait
pas la cohabitation même fin de non
recevoir pour un régime présidentiel
défendu par philippe séguin un régime
qui ouvrirait la porte à toutes les
aventures
jacques chirac ne veut pas changer de
constitution et réalistes ils jugent
sans doute qu'après trois défaites
électorales avec une droite éclatée un
rpr en crise et les remous autour de
paris il n'a pas les moyens d'une
bataille frontale alors je calcul bien
97 ça fait jusqu'à 2002 c'est à dire
qu'il va continuer comme ça cette
cohabitation constructif comme une élite
oui absolument c'est l'a rappelé le
choix des français le président se veut
au dessus de la mêlée il tance
l'opposition pour son absence de projet
et ses querelles de personnes
insupportable at il dit
d'où ce soir un peu d'embarras et
d'amertume à droite et puis il joue
l'usure du gouvernement à laquelle il
entend bien contribuer en revendiquant
cette différence celle de la droite de
la responsabilité face à la gauche qui
réglemente en pointant les erreurs d'un
gouvernement qui gaspillent la
croissance car il ne réduit pas les
impôts et n'engage pas les réformes
nécessaires
et puis enfin en multipliant par ses
déplacements en province ces liens avec
le pays réel alors au total un président
arbitre engagé pour une stratégie un peu
mitterrandienne du temps mais qui pose
une question de jacques chirac de lionel
jospin qui va user l'autre merci gérard
quant au premier ministre justement qui
s'est déplacé juste après la réception à
l'elysée dans son canton de cintegabelle
en haute-garonne pas question de
commenter les propos de jacques chirac
la fête nationale à cintegabelle c'était
football et cassoulet reportage laurent
hakim jean yves blanc
à chacun sa garden party celle du
premier ministre ce boulet nettement
plus intimes sur ses terres de
cintegabelle quelques heures après
l'intervention de jacques chirac lionel
jospin s'est mis au vert en famille avec
quelques amis autour d'un match de
football à la fiche
l'équipe de matignon en blanc contre
l'équipe locale en jaune impartialité de
façade d'un côté les amis de l'autre les
collaborateurs mais ce qui fait la
différence ce sont les deux fils du
premier ministre ce sujet dans l'équipe
matignon même dans l'euphorie de
l'égalisation à la mi-temps pas question
de commentaires politiques même s'ils
n'ont mérité d'égaliser l'appui dix
minutes quand même dominé un match nul
au visage et les combats pourtant c'est
d'avoir deux chances de gagner quoiqu'il
arrive je reste sur devant la tournure
de la rencontre lionel jospin reconnaît
qu'il préfère passer du côté des
vainqueurs du premier ministre
visiblement serein il n'y aura ni
polémique ni accroc dans la cohabitation
score final 3 2 pour les cinq gars
belloy matignon n'aura pas réussi la
victoire à l'extérieur tandis que lionel
jospin expédie quelques affaires
courantes la petite place du village
prépare un cassoulet géant pour 1000
convives
la garden party de cintegabelle
s'achèvera tard dans la nuit en iran
l'ordre règne ce soir les étudiants sont
devenus des agitateurs et des
contre-révolutionnaires dans la bouche
des ayatollahs qui ont engagé une
répression très fermes pour mettre fin à
la contestation ils ont su organiser un
vaste défilé anti étudiants pour
démontrer leur pouvoir les conservateurs
ont même reçu hier l'appui du président
réformiste khatami commentaires gérard
griesbeck
une marée humaine comme il ya 20 ans
comme au début de la révolution
islamique
les partisans du régime ont répondu
massivement des centaines de milliers
sans doute plus à l'appel du guide de la
révolution l'ayatollah khamenei les
slogans sont toujours les mêmes mort à
l'amérique mort à israël
partout des portraits de l'imam khomeiny
fondateur du régime mort il y a dix ans
et un grand absent le président rami
dont s'est réclamé le mouvement étudiant
pendant six jours
pas un seul portrait de lui bien qu'il
ait lâché le mouvement hier au soir dans
un discours à la télévision
une manifestation pour la restauration
de l'ordre moral où les femmes étaient
venus en grand nombre
on est là pour montrer que cette
révolution que l'on a faites il ya 20
ans on ne l'abandonnera pas facilement
cette révolution à la fête avec le sens
de notre jeunesse
la police n'a pas eu à intervenir
elle a simplement canaliser la foule le
long du boulevard de la révolution qui
s'étend sur plusieurs kilomètres près de
l'université aujourd'hui fermé des
responsables du régime
écoute le vice président du parlement
massalé y est ce n'est pas un individu
qui a été mise en cause par les
étudiants c'est le guide de la
révolution
auch mise en cause par la main de
l'étranger par le colonisateur
internationale ce soir on a l'impression
que les conservateurs ont repris le
dessus que le mouvement étudiant a été
brisé lors de la répression a sonné
certains dirigeants disent qu'il
pourrait y avoir des exécutions
quant au président rata me paraît
maintenant isolé
au kosovo madame louise arbour procureur
du tribunal pénal international s'est
rendu aujourd'hui aux villages de
shilling dans le sud ouest de la
province dans ce village on vient de
retrouver un charnier au moins treize
enfants y ont été massacrés madame à
rebours n'a pas caché son émotion
elle a répété qu'il ne faisait aucun
doute pour elle que les auteurs de ces
crimes seraient traduits en justice
commentaire jérôme baugnies louise
arbour procureur du tribunal pénal
international pour l'ex-yougoslavie
arrive sur un nouveau site présumée de
crime contre l'humanité
ici dans le village de thiais line et
des enquêteurs britanniques de l'otan
ont découvert les corps de 21 albanais
du kosovo dont 18 femmes et enfants il
aurait été tué le 25 mars quelques
heures après le début des bombardements
de l'otan
abattu à bout portant par des forces
serbes d'après des témoignages leurs
corps calcinés ont été emportés pour
être examinés par des médecins légistes
a pointé par le tribunal
les criminels de guerre ont maintenant
face à eux toute la détermination de
louise arbour evry chaque pas que nous
venons chaque jarnier de couverts chaque
inculpation est un pas irréversible en
avant je ne sais pas quand on pourra
raconter l'histoire d'aujourd'hui dans
le prétoire du tribunal de la haye mais
sans aucun doute tu arriveras madame la
procureure s'est dit bouleversé par les
nombreux témoignages recueillis auprès
des familles des victimes au 1er juillet
dernier la kfor force de l'otan au
kosovo avait dénombré 150 sites de
massacres présumés
beaucoup de travail en perspective pour
louise arbour et les trente experts du
tribunal pénal international le
ravitaillement de la station spatiale
mir pourra bien se faire dans les jours
qui viennent le kazakhstan a levé son
interdiction des tirs de fusée depuis la
base de baïkonour sur son territoire un
accord financier sur est intervenu entre
la russie et le kazakhstan le lancement
du vaisseau ravitailleur est prévue
vendredi ou dimanche prochain la
commission européenne favorable à la
reprise des exportations des viandes
bovines britannique l'embargo sur le
boeuf britannique sera levé à partir du
1er août sous conditions cet embargo
avait été décrété
plus de trois ans après les différents
cadres de la maladie de la vache folle
commentaires cyrille devaud
les steaks anglais bientôt de retour
dans nos assiettes
l'embargo sur le boeuf britannique sera
officiellement levé le 1er août prochain
une décision que les producteurs
d'outre-manche attendait depuis trois
ans est passé bien de sortir enfin de la
crise c'est bien que tout le travail que
nous avons fait depuis trois ans soit
reconnu m
depuis le 27 mars 96 date de l'embargo
les anglais ont employé les grands
moyens pour faire disparaître leurs
vaches folles des millions de bêtes
infectées par l'encéphalite spongiforme
bovine ont été tués puis incinéré les
abattoirs anglais sont désormais soumis
à des contrôles très stricts
un système de fichage informatique a été
mise en place enfin les farines animales
à l'origine de la maladie sont
strictement interdites dans
l'alimentation des bovins
grâce à ces mesures le royaume uni a
convaincu l'europe que ces vaches
étaient à nouveau parfaitement saine si
je n'étais pas sûr à 100% que la viande
anglaise est saine je ne voterai pas la
levée de l'embargo
c'est clair je suis convaincu que le
boeuf et 5 sous les conditions mises en
place pour le futur des conditions très
strictes imposées par la commission
européenne
seule la viande désossée provenant
d'animaux âgés de moins de 30 mois
pourra être exportée l'origine de cette
viande devra clairement apparaître la
france estime que seule la transparence
peut garantir la qualité du veuf anglais
concernant l'importation des boeufs aux
hormones des etats-unis du canada
monsieur chirac affirmant que
l'entretien qu'il nous a accordé 13
heures que l'union européenne
importerait pas cette viande
contrairement à ce que recommande
l'organisation mondiale du commerce à
nancy en meurthe et moselle
l'inauguration d'une rue préfet claude
erignac l'ancien préfet de corse qui fut
assassiné à ajaccio le 6 février train
18 8 auparavant préfet de ce département
de meurthe et moselle
la cérémonie a eu lieu en présence de
madame erignac qui s'est exprimé sur l'
enquête menée pour découvrir les auteurs
du meurtre de son mari commenté retirer
curtet
le vent n'en porte pas les souvenirs de
nancy cette rue qui arrive sur la place
stanislas au coeur de la ville porte
désormais le nom du préfet assassiné en
corse
sa femme dominique revenait ce matin sur
les pas de son mari représentant de
l'état ici autant difficile de la fin de
la sidérurgie
rarement cette femme discrète déterminée
ne fait part de ses états d'âme mais
elle s'est pour une fois confié à
quelques journalistes
j'attends que l'enquêté se poursuive et
que pour moi je pense qu'elle n'est pas
tout à fait fini d'abord il ya toujours
des acolytes des commandos qui courent
toujours
et puis ensuite on pourrait chercher les
commanditaires aussi donc j'espère que
tout le monde restera mobilisé
restaurant ensemble pour avancer dans
cette enquête la faire avancer
pour elle il est clair que l' enquête
n'a pas abouti sur tous les points
même si cinq hommes sont sous les
verrous un membre du commando est encore
en fuite
pour madame erignac l'ampleur de leur
geste est telle qu'il implique forcément
une prise de décision à un autre niveau
à lille des résultats d'analysés adn
viennent de permettent de confondre
l'auteur du viol et du meurtre d'une
enfant de 4 ans crime commis il y à 7
ans est restée jusque-là inexpliqué
explication parce qu'elle dit c'est bon
nadia avait 4 ans en 92
quand un homme l'a violée et assassinée
et depuis les enquêteurs faisait chou
blanc
mais hier face à l'évidence des analyses
adn
un suspect de 32 ans avos l'homme était
déjà en détention provisoire dans une
autre affaire de viol sur mineure
les policiers ont comparé son code
génétique avec celui des traces relevées
sur nadia il ya sept ans les résultats
sont fiables à 99%
du coup les enquêteurs espèrent faire la
même comparaison dans deux autres viols
et meurtres non élucidés
nathalie 7 ans et cathy neuf ans la
recherche de la carte génétique est
désormais aussi courantes que l'analyse
des empreintes digitales et comme les
empreintes digitales
elle repose avant tout sur la rigueur
des premières constatations
ici par exemple les officiers ont saisi
sur les lieux d'un viol tous les objets
susceptibles d'être maculé le sueur de
sang de salive ou de sperme et tous les
cheveux et les poils
il faut alors aux techniciens identifier
les traces et en tirer un code génétique
les tâches qui sont apparus sur le tee
shirt était bien du sperme et donc le
t-shirt supporter rien du sterne toutes
ces petites barres
on va lire sur différents systèmes on va
pouvoir obtenir l'empreinte génétique de
l'adn de départ en plus de la
comparaison au cas par cas
les enquêteurs peuvent aussi désormais
comparer leurs résultats avec les cartes
génétiques des hommes déjà condamnés
dans ce type d'affaires le taux de
récidive est énorme
le fichier des empreintes génétiques est
donc un très net progrès
la france est le troisième pays en
europe à se doter d'une telle banque de
données du sport du cyclisme c'était
aujourd'hui la 10e étape du tour de
france avec la terrible et très célèbre
arrivée à l'alpe d'huez près de 120 km
de course
on retiendra l'échappée belle mais vaine
de stéphane heulot la victoire malgré
une embûches inattendues de l'italien
giuseppe guerini et le maillot jaune
toujours porté par lance armstrong
le reportage est flanc gautreau et
philippe deslandes une étape mythique le
rêve de tout grimpeur le summum d'une
carrière guérini a failli tout raté à
cause d'un spectateur inconscient en
haut de l'alpe d'huez
on atteint des sommets l'hystérie
heureusement pour lui du gp guérini
l'italien de l'équipe allemande deutsche
telekom s'est relevé tout de suite pour
aller s'offrir en solitaire une superbe
victoire une victoire qui aurait pu être
française dans la descente du mont-cenis
stéphane heulot et thierry bourguignon
tente un coup insensé qui a bien failli
marcher il s'échappe à 150 kilomètres de
l'arrivée une manière comme une autre de
fêter le 14 juillet après avoir escaladé
la croix de fer les voilà au pied de
l'alpe d'huez
autant dire aux portes de l'enfer pas de
miracle pour bourguignons qui laisse
partir le lot plus fort et plus frais le
lot qui lui a su régler le cas des
spectateurs trop pressant mais il reste
21 virages à négocier pour l'ancien
champion de france il y aura quelques
virages de trop à trois kilomètres du
sommet il est repris par le groupe du
maillot jaune
j'ai pensé à ma famille j'ai pensé à
tout le moins difficile quand on a passé
je suis penser le cyclisme se passe ici
parce qu'une victoire ça comme ça
j'en ai fait aboutir certaines idées et
je crois que membre heureusement je suis
pas récompensé on l'aura compris les
cyclistes français se sentent isolés
dans leur combat contre le dopage
armstrong cinquième aujourd'hui qui
conforte sa place de leader à jeter le
trouble dans les esprits
les coureurs n'en parle pas mais le
doute a germé au coeur qu'on peut être
surpris
ce coureur né n'est plus le même c'est
bien préparés aussi sans routine
je crois qu'au delà sondés on ne peut
pas peut pas tirer d'enseignement
supplémentaires aujourd'hui en tout cas
moi je me refuse à le faire lance
amstrong est sans doute soulagé d'avoir
si bien passé les alpes
l'américain a écrasé ses adversaires
mais at il d'ores et déjà gagné le tour
difficile à dire alors qu'on n'a pas
encore passé les pyrénées
pourtant ce soir à l'alpe d'huez la
plupart de ses adversaires pensent que
le tour est joué
et le maillot à pois rouges qui
distingue le meilleur grimpeur est
depuis hier porté par richard virenque
qui n'en fallait pas plus pour recréer
une ambiance passionnée au tour de celui
que l'on crut très longtemps
inacceptable au tour de france richard
virenque et 6e au classement général et
il déclenche de nouveau les
enthousiasmes reportage nathanaël de
rincquesen et alain poirier sur la route
du tour
l'aviron qu magna se conjugue à l'infini
pour devenir fan
il n'y a pas d'âge certains font ça avec
plus de sérieux
cet homme est peintre et ça se voit
depuis quelques heures
virenque est redevenu le meilleur
grimpeur du tour alors les petits pois
reviennent à la mode un peu partout dans
l'alpe d'huez obstinément ils le
soutiennent
passionnément ils l'encouragent virenque
est de retour avec son maillot fétiche
tout un symbole
mais bon moment
pourquoi ça il a quand même ramené
quatre fois d'affilée quatre années
sipa d'emprunt
trois suspects ordinaires pas recouvré
que défend dans les 21 virages de l'alpe
d'huez
richard virenque est un peu partout
sur les camions sur la route à flanc de
montagne
virenque fait partie du paysage
explications sans vie reims s est pas
une véritable étape l'alpe d'huez
et puis je suis là quatre jours
uniquement pour avoir la place dans les
premiers plusieurs heures d'attentes
parfois plusieurs jours passés sur le
banc de la route et à l'arrivée
seulement quelques secondes de bonheur
leur idole vient de passer sont même les
regarder mais ils ont l'habitude
demain ils seront encore là sur la route
du tour à attendre virenque pour
l'encourager cinéma avec un film
intitulé en attendant la neige le titre
est trompeur car que c'est une car
l'action se déroule la nuit du 14
juillet ce long métrage est le fruit
d'un pari réussi de quatre jeunes de
béridier qui raconte une course
poursuite entre un chef de bande et un
boxeur reconverti en portier de nuit
reportage frédéric bonnet tout a
commencé un soir comme celui ci par un
rêve de gosse quatre fils de la banlieue
qui voulait faire du cinéma ont réussi
leur pari ce soir comme des militants
chevronnés ils collent des affiches mais
pas n'importe lesquelles ce sont celles
de leur propre film allait bien à la
petite fierté c'est rigolo quoi est ce
que tu me disais quand même des noms il
ya la tête de diaby drissa la tête de
jazz il ya emmanuel il ya les petits
tickets là donc c'est plutôt amusante
tu as l'impression que tu as vraiment
mener ce truc jusqu'au bout voir
ce film sans budget réussi à nous
plonger dans un monde surréaliste
il nous raconte l'histoire d'un boxeur
poursuivi par son destin pour tourner
cette scène
la production a astucieusement profité
de l'entretien habituel du périphérique
installé à saint denis où ils payent un
loyer dérisoire
les quatre hommes orchestres étaient
tous demandeurs d'emploi ils ont réuni
péniblement 59 ans pour créer une sarl
est empruntée 800000 francs
on devrait pas faire des films quand on
n'a pas d'argent puisque puisque c'est
une industrie et que c'est anarchy
demande qui demandent du financement et
on pourrait faire de la peinture mais
on s'est dit qu'on était dans un pays
riche et
il fallait faire coûte que coûte ce film
c'est ça ce qui fait les hommes iman
pêche à un boeuf en pleine course
djamel bouras lui aussi a été séduit par
cette aventure
et comme les autres comédiens et des
techniciens il n'a pas de salaire il est
temps participation en avant-première
dans les salles d'aubervilliers
l'équipe du film souhaite qu'en
attendant la neige serve d'exemple à
tous ceux qui ont des idées
le seul message ce propos daniel salle
tout un peu d'espoir c'est que tous
autant que vous êtes là c'est un moment
donné vous avez envie de faire d'être
les choses à son possible il faut qu'il
faut tous les mettre tous les gens de
banlieue il faut y croire
les défauts et les imperfections de ce
premier film sont largement effacée par
le souffle qui lui a donné le mérite
d'exister
et en attendant la neige est diffusé à
partir d'aujourd'hui donc sur les écrans
en france à la rochelle première journée
première soirée des francofolies déjà
âgée de 15 ans on a rajeuni invités
ouvert à d'autres expressions
linguistiques mais la chanson
francophone reste plus que jamais à
l'honneur avec zazie qui est auvergnat
sur ces francofolies rochelaise cher à
jean louis foulquier qui francofolies
qui se prolongeront jusqu'à dimanche
reportage éric perrin et christophe
vignal on a beau s'appeler zazie et ne
pas savoir un métro à prendre faire
l'ouverture d'un festival comme les
francofolies de la rochelle c'est
toujours un peu stressant
une fois atteint un peu
chaque année
pour vous le disais stressant limite
renversant bref un festival est toujours
une date particulière pour un artiste
sans doute aussi parce que là plus
qu'ailleurs il voit vraiment son public
ça donne une rémission plus réelle de du
spectacle ce qui peut être aussi un
quelque chose qui n'est pas forcément
souhaitable moi je sais que j'aime bien
aussi
fermez les yeux et imaginez la salle et
imaginer un voyage plutôt que de les
voir bien réel devant moi je te crois
pas
je ne chasse pas les étoiles mais toute
fin de match des bulles à quiconque pour
un
mais le plus étonnant cette année reste
l'arrivée avec les cardigans de
l'anglais au royaume de la francophonie
une ouverture linguistique qui vise à
apporter un second souffle aux
francofolies qui pourrait bien devenir
l'an 2000 d euros phonique
voilà les francofolies de la rochelle
c'est jusqu'à dimanche donc sa région la
fin de ce journal je vous rappelle les
informations concernant le défilé
traditionnel sur les champs elysées
aujourd'hui où l'on a remarqué la
présence de la guerre de royale
marocaine celle du roi hassan ii au côté
du président jacques chirac
la république répondant à nos questions
on dirait du jardin oui lisait partir de
13h a exprimé son refus du quinquennat
son choix d'une cohabitation
constructive mais aussi ses critiques à
l'égard du gouvernement qui n'utilise
top estime-t-il la croissance pour
baisser les charges et les impôts
dans quelques secondes la météo avec
patrice drevet à zéro heure dix laurence
ostolaza pour le dernier journal de la
rédaction demain c'est 1,50 dans la 4
vérités françoise laborde recevra le
député julien dray à 13h vous trouverez
carole gaessler et rachid arhab à demain
20h bonsoir merci